Sei nudo Sentilo come rimbomba il rumore
dell'onda al rumore dell'onda Quando ero
ragazzina cantavamo questa canzoncina
inventata dopo giornate intense di
scuola di vela per me le isole erano
così
Belle perché era estate il mare
romantico il caldo rilassante
poi ho avuto la pessima idea di iniziare
a lavorare nella comunicazione della
crisi climatica e questo ritornello ha
iniziato ad assumere un significato
radicalmente diverso
l'ultimo report dell'ipcc ci dice che le
isole sono fra i luoghi più minacciati
dalla crisi climatica
incendi tempeste siccità alluvioni gli
oceani si alzano e se i mari si alzano
di 30/40 cm o più come nelle ipotesi
peggiori sono quelle della strada che
stiamo percorrendo
e le Maldive hanno un'altitudine media
di un metro e mezzo
Beh vi lascio immaginare
per le isole affrontare la crisi
climatica adesso è una questione di vita
o di morte
però un mio amico mi ha detto una volta
che è una cosa importante cioè la peggio
le ricostruiamo a Gardaland Ci mettiamo
Due Palme quattro manghi un paio di
Cocchi e anche un problema in meno
perché soffre il mal di mare Siamo a
posto poi se sulle Isole c'è un quarto
delle specie di uccelli e piante del
pianeta
stiamo bene anche senza Io c'ho il cane
e il gatto mi faccio ben di altre grane
da affrontare
Allora ho pensato ai migranti climatici
entro il 2050 potrebbero superare i 200
milioni pensate tra Italia e mezzo
e che vengono Soprattutto dalle aree
costiere
lui ha fatto spallucce Andrea
costruiremo un muro bello alto Tanto
siamo allenati ormai
certo Peccato solo che dalla parte
sbagliata del muro potrebbe esserci
l'Italia
come potete immaginare non abbiamo
raggiunto un comune accordo quella sera
Ma al di là di tutti i motivi per cui a
noi importa non perdere le isole e che
alla fine possiamo riassumere nel fatto
che tutto interconnesso è che un sistema
la salute di un sistema dipende dalla
salute di tutte le sue parti a noi le
isole in porta a guardarle da vicino
perché parafrasando il biogeografo
system Order sono veri e propri pianeti
in miniatura dove se è vero che il
rapporto essere umano e ambiente mostra
in maniera cristallina a tutti i
problemi È vero anche che possono essere
laboratori di soluzioni
perché se ci pensate hanno delle sfide
enormi da affrontare per giocare a
questo gioco della società contemporanea
devono importare quasi tutto oltre a noi
turisti cibo merci carburante pure acqua
In tanti casi pensate che ha preso una
delle isole più selvagge d'alaska Dove
vive Emi una mia carissima amica una
mela come quella che avete mangiato
nella pausa deve prendere tre aerei un
idrovolante farsi Qualche km in barca se
il mare non è in tempesta per arrivare
sei sfida di questo genere e sei Nel
mezzo del niente più assoluto o in palio
muori me lo spiegava Emy appunto mentre
eravamo su questo sentiero di
pietracuminate grosse così che lei
chiamava strada centinaia di chilometri
dalla civiltà senza telefoni e cercavamo
di riparare la jeep in panne con i miei
lacci delle scarpe Infatti ho i sandali
adesso fra l'altro questa Emy comunque
tutto per dire sì ce l'abbiamo fatta
alla fine sennò non sarai qua a parlare
con voi ma al di là di questo che i
problemi sono incentivi a cercare
soluzioni
e le isole questo lo sanno benissimo
Danimarca 4000 abitanti fino a
pochissimo tempo fa basavano tutta la
loro energia
sull'importazione di combustibili
fossili pagavano è come se pagavano o
tra le bollette benessere salute
poi c'è stata educazione cooperativa
energetica e responsabilità e benefici
condivisi e a partire dal 2005 producono
più energia dal rinnovabile di quella di
cui hanno bisogno e la esportano pure la
gente è contenta ragazzi della mia età
ci vanno a vivere perché se sta bene
anzi sono servizi Aria pulita lavoro
e la vicina non è da meno ero un
isoletta che produce il 140%
dell'energia
alle necessaria e cosa fa con restante
Ellen un traghetto elettrico con 40 km
di autonomia e da record mondiale Anche
perché per le isole il settore trasporti
è vitale ma è anche uno dei più
impattanti e così mentre i grandi stati
discutono fra loro sul fatto che
traghetti elettrici sono utopia
idealistici
Aero non lo sanno e continuano andare
avanti e indietro su un traghetto
elettrico loro
per le isole
Queste sono sono sfide di tutti i giorni
che si riportano fino all'islanda dove
addirittura forse stupidi stufi di fare
record solo per le pecore per abitante
hanno iniziato a produrre con il
idroelettrico e geotermico e adesso sono
il maggior produttore di energia verde
procapita al mondo e ha preso questo Emy
ha smesso di mangiare mele che arrivano
sempre marzo In ogni caso e mangia
mirtilli i ragazzi mi hanno mostrato
Come coltivare ortaggi o agricoltura ai
dronika le famiglie usano i vecchi
copertoni perché fanno per coltivare per
fare l'orto perché drenano l'acqua e
trattengono il calore le zucchine sono
spaziali
e a sud è a sud del mondo Alphonse alle
Seychelles con le colleghe caraibiche di
Saint Kitchen Nevis che sono simbolo
dell'ego turismo tilos in Grecia la
prima isola dello Stato a diventare
autosufficiente a livello energetico le
Azzorre in Portogallo con 60 re marine
protette e quattro riserve biosfera
UNESCO fra le destinazioni più
sostenibili al mondo e gli errori sulla
stessa strada
in Italia non ce la caviamo un gran bene
che dire però c'è qualche Faro nella
tempesta cioè Capraia che ha eliminato i
fossili della sua produzione energetica
c'è Ustica che sta installando pannelli
solari in maniera compulsiva l'isola
Pontina di Santo Stefano che sta
puntando tutto sul turismo sostenibile
però ancora chi se ne importa chi se ne
importa se ci pensiamo sono in pochi ma
sono piccole isole piccole isole di
comunità non fanno che distogliere
l'attenzione dalle sfide globali da chi
inquina davvero un altro modo di fare
Green washing speculare fare una fascia
transizione Sono gocce
gocce destinate letteralmente ad
evaporare
e se ci pensate tutto questo è vero È
verissimo l'isola È un puntino fronte
alle sfide globali fronte alle
responsabilità dei colossi economici e
politici
Ma è anche vero che come ripeteva la
sociologa Margaret Mead traduzione mia
non dubitate mai che un piccolo gruppo
di persone impegnate possa cambiare il
mondo perché a conti fatti è l'unica
cosa che sia mai stata davvero in grado
di farlo
perché le isole non sono minuscole come
singoli individui ma non sono neanche
così complesse come gli stati continenti
le nazioni perché psicologicamente
abbiamo bisogno di vedere i risultati
per andare avanti e se a livello globale
anche se cambiassimo rotta
immediatamente cosa da fare che non
stiamo facendo i risultati ci
metterebbero di più a mostrarsi di
quello che dura un mandato elettorale
che spiega anche perché i politici non
interessi così tanto affrontare la crisi
climatica questa è un'altra storia sulle
Isole I risultati si possono vedere
Quasi a tempo zero e dimostrare Nei
fatti Cosa si ottiene con un cambio di
approccio sistemico
e una volta che la possibilità diventa
realtà che si può fare
allora sì che le isole possono fare un
grande Ecco e lo sentite come rimbomba
Allora il rumore dell'onda E fa sì che
le idee si diffondano al posto delle
macchie di petrolio e che le buone
pratiche ce ne raccogliamo sulla
spiaggia al posto della plastica e che
le reti fra persone
sostituiscano Quelle a strascico invece
di seminare morte costruiscano veramente
relazioni e connessioni
Forse invece di chiederci se davvero le
piccole cose piccole a Scala servono a
qualcosa dovremmo adoperarsi per
diffonderle adattarle e replicarle su
larga Scala
che perché le isole ormai non sono più
soltanto quelle lambite dal mare
Le isole sono piccole comunità in questo
mare che la Terra e le piccole comunità
sono isole
nell'oceano appunto che la società e
guardatevi Ma guardatevi se non siete
isole voi ognuno con un'identità delle
sfide dei sogni tutti i naviganti in
questo mare in tempesta eppure
interconnessi siamo gli uni con gli
altri
e come fare allora come fare a fare
davvero Ecco qui tre spunti 1 pensa come
un'isola lo cantava Bertoli affrontare
la vita a muso duro con un piede nel
passato e lo sguardo dritto è aperto Nel
futuro se sei sotto acqua per metà dico
io Guardi impari e nuoti e più veloce
che puoi per salvare la metà che resta e
il vittimismo non è ammesso
semplicemente perché chi si rassegna è
perduto due impara a fare l'isola Guarda
impara dalle isole di terra di roccia
quelle sociali E diffondi Scusate
replica gli esempi positivi
adattali e tre
si isola
arrangiati ma arrangiati e affronta con
un pizzico di coraggio di creatività un
buon paio di lacci delle scarpe se ce li
hai tutte le sfide uniche che ci pone
questo mondo perché nessuno lo farà il
tuo posto
E perché Ricordiamoci che anche se
puntini anche se tutte diverse le isole
devono scegliere di fare arcipelago per
far fronte alle sfide globali
Lo sentite come rimbomba il rumore
dell'onda
Come diceva
la posizione Nord Ricordiamoci che
nessuna isola
neppure la più sperduta
nell'oceano e tanto isolata quanto la
terra nell'universo è davvero è plasmata
nient'altro che dalle onde Delle nostre
scelte Grazie
[Applauso]